RYAN (VOICEOVER): Wendy came
by with a motorcycle that
needed some custom touches.
But Wendy ain't just
your average rider.
She's actually at competitive
racing motorcycle rider.
And this bike is a
rare racing motorcycle.
She wanted us to move
some things around
on it for her leisurely
2000 mile rides.
And Ryan did his
amazing custom touches
on it to make this thing as
cool as the lady that owns it.
Shannon, you come on, brother.
Bring out that beautiful bike.
Oh, wow.
Just from here.
Walk around, tell
us what you think.
WENDY: She's beautiful.
SHANNON (VOICEOVER): This
was a different kind of job
for a different kind of rider.
And man, I think it came out as
cool as the lady who owns her.
Wendy's the real deal
when it comes to racing.
So she wanted to keep all
the performance of that XR
1200 while giving her some style
and creature comforts as well.
Wendy packs a lot of coolness
into a small package.
So we adjusted the
handlebars and the seat
so she could sit and
steer comfortably.
And adjusted the kickstand
so she can actually reach it.
Ryan took the original
look of that 1200
and added some perfectly subtle
touches that let the world
know this is a special bike.
And it belongs to a
very special lady.
- First impression.
- This is amazing.
It's beautiful.
It's more than I
could have imagined.
RYAN: I love it.
Shannon, walk Wendy around
everything that you've done.
The bars, you needed
them pulled back to you.
- Yep.
- Which was great.
I mean, I feel comfortable
on this bike, so.
We did repad the seat--
- Nice.
And bring it down.
SHANNON: She can slide-- yeah.
Slide around.
RYAN: Drag her knees
around corners.
Imagine that.
I don't know if I'll
be dragging my knees.
Your sissy bar is on here
so you can hold your pack.
This is just an extended bag if
you were taking a longer trip.
OK.
It looks fantastic.
MAN: Well, speaking of looks.
Ryan, please explain the
beautiful visuals on this.
I'm a huge fan
of gold leafing.
And it was used
heavily in racing
because that was the
original reflective material.
So I did all the
lettering in gold leaf.
You can't be missed.
I wanted to commemorate your
cannonball experience, and
especially your Isle of Man.
But I didn't want to
stand out and be gaudy.
I wanted it to be classy.
So I did that in gold leaf.
It's perfect.
MAN: Subtle, beautiful,
the styling bro, I love it.
It was stressful.
I mean, it was worse than
doing something for you.
Cause she--
MAN: Well, bro.
She's badass.
MAN: That's the key.
Not that you're not, but--
Trust me, man.
I would not do the things
that Wendy has done.
You and me both.
We all love this
bike like crazy.
This thing is totally cool.
How do you feeling about it?
I can't wait to ride it.
That's the best
compliment I can give.
It's the best thing I own.
Don't let us
stand in your way.
I've got one more thing for you.
Give me a second.
OK.
MAN: Tell me about the
cannonball experience.
OK.
So I was fortunate
enough to be asked to be
on a relay team across country.
And I ran Pulaski, Virginia
to Memphis, Tennessee.
It was 520 miles in six
hours and 15 minutes.
That's amazing.
Oh my Lord.
You can't do any of those
things in most of the states
without that.
Oh my goodness, look at this.
This is fantastic.
Helmets are so personal.
Look at it, it matches.
Yes.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
- Are you kidding me?
- Thank you, Thank you.
Thank you for trusting
us with this bike.
The bike is
magnificent, we dig it.
But the story behind it just
makes it so much cooler.
WENDY: She's beautiful.
MAN: Well you know what
would look more beautiful?
Seeing you slip on
your lid and take
this thing down the street.
We should do that.
I think you should.
I'm not going with you.
You're not going--
I was going to ask, you
want to ride on the back?
Nope, nope.
Not after hearing your stories.
No way.
I'll just watch from way behind.
She looks like she's
going over 100 miles an hour
just standing.
MAN: Right?
Right?
Real gloves, real lid,
she got on the real shoes.
Look at this.
Wendy, you rock.
Thanks, guys.
MAN (VOICEOVER):
Man, meeting Wendy,
you wouldn't guess in 100 years
that she's a motorcycle racer.
But watching her throw
her leg over this thing
and taking off down the
road, it was obvious she
knew what she was doing.
That is one cool lady.
She's going to be enjoying
this bike for miles,
and miles, and miles.
And that gives me smiles.